[Musique]
je suis allé au dans une réception où
j'ai bu beaucoup de champagne
juste ce qu'il fallait pour être bien
et quand je dis bien c'était que
vraiment je me sentais bien dans ma peau
et ce jour là on m'a fait beaucoup de
compliments
wc se passait chez mes parents et les
amis de mes parents ont dit lorsque
c'est dommage il ya longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas vu si gai c'est dommage
qu'on ne peut pas vous voit plus souvent
que sourire etc et tout à coup je me
suis dit ça c'est le champagne et de ce
jour là je me suis servi de l'alcool
pour essayer de retrouver ces moments
autorisant ces moments où je me sentais
bien et où enfin j'arrive à parler avec
les autres et puis petit à petit ça
dépassait beaucoup de beaucoup les
limites que
possible j'ai essayé de retrouver ses
moments d'euphorie que je n'ai jamais
retrouvé et j'ai commencé à culpabiliser
alors ça a été caché les bouteilles
boire dans la voiture
changez de commerçants lâche toujours se
cacher se cacher se cacher
pendant quatre ans étais le calvaire
pendant quatre ans j'ai essayé de
m'arrêter de boire et puis après bah il
suffisait je sais pas moi d'une petite
fête d'un prétexte quelconque en
l'occurrence je me souviens pas grave
pour le mariage de ma soeur à l'époque
mon père buvant aussi on avait décidé de
s'arrêter de boire puis quand il eut le
mariage de ma soeur on a dit qu'est ce
qu'on fait alors exceptionnellement pour
pas pour lui faire plaisir on a bu une
coupe de champagne et la machine s'est
remise en route c'est un peu si vous
voulez en moi il ya comme une pompe dès
que je touche un seul verre inverse
seulement et bien ça y est toute la
pompe est amorcée il m'en faut doute
lors sa jeu j'étais un peu déboussolée
parce que je comprenais pas comment les
autres pouvaient boire normalement et
moi moi il m'en fallait encore plus
encore plus quand les autres s'arrêtait
mois il m'en fallait
la membrolle sur choisille près de tours
dans le seul centre de cure en france
consacrée essentiellement à l'alcoolisme
travail toute une équipe médico
hospitalière entraîné au traitement de
ces malades complexe difficile et
parfois décourageant que sont les
alcooliques
classique cure de désintoxication et
tout autre traitement repose sur la même
base on soigne une maladie malgré
dictons et préjugés
malgré l' influence des valeurs mythique
investi par la société dans l'alcool
nous sommes de culture romaine
catholique c'est à dire que nous
reconnaissons comme valables les textes
sacrés et si vous lisez les textes
sacrés si ça vous est arrivé vous lirez
dans l'ecclésiaste que le vin réjouit le
coeur des bons et now le coeur des
méchants ce qui voudrait dire que le vin
est à sion de vérité qui ne veut pas
faire de mal un sujet bien connaître
mais que par contre il révèle les vices
létard cachée d'un homme et qu'en même
temps il punit et c'est pour ça que
pendant très longtemps on a estimé que
les maladie alcoolique était le fait de
gens qui abusent et qui est exagéré des
sujets tard et des sujets vicieux et on
retrouve au niveau de la france deux
suivants les caractères des français
deux positions ce qui condamne les
malades alcooliques en dix ans s'ils
sont malades c'est bien fait ce qui leur
arrive parce qu'ils n'avaient qu'à être
raisonnable et ceux qui essayent coûte
que coûte de ne pas les condamner en
disant mais c'est pas du tout de leur
faute s'il boit c'est parce que ce sont
tous des malades mentaux ou ce sont des
gens qui ont un travail qui ne leur
convient pas ou ce sont des gens qui
vivent dans des conditions de famille de
logements créés terrain qui ne sont pas
satisfaisants donc les maladie
alcoolique jusqu'à présent ont toujours
été considérés comme des problèmes
moraux et non comme des maladies qui
relève des de la métier
aujourd'hui encore certains jugent
d'autres menacent d'autres encore
parlent de tares de vis il en est même
qui projette à tout instant le film de
l'apocalypse gros plan sur le foie du
cirrhotiques long travelling sur la
démence le délirium et l'agonie
à qui désirent trancher le lien
fascinant qui l'unît à l'alcool on ne
demande pas de promesses d'ivrogne on
lui apprend tout simplement qu'il est un
malade un intoxiqué et que son organisme
est en quelque sorte allergique à
l'alcool
contre cette allergie la science de 1976
ne peut rien l'alcoolique doit en
prendre son parti et savoir s'engager
gravement profondément à ne plus boire
je suis allé jusque dans un asile
psychiatrique
simplement parce que j'avais été à la
sécurité sociale demandé une cure de
désintoxication
je suis arrivé la conduite en voiture
par mon mari qui est descendu que tel au
bureau je suis pas bougé de la voiture
la coupable tout pouvait m'arriver de
toulouse et j'ai été accueilli par deux
surveillantes et la gym la première
grille qui s'est fermé derrière moi je
crois que c'est ce bruit de portes qui
se ferment de conscrits dans les
serrures c'est un bruit que je
n'oublierai jamais personnellement je
suis passé à travers beaucoup de choses
je faisais semblant de ne pas voir je me
sentais j'avais l'impression que j'étais
là que c'était bien fait pour ma pomme
que c'était c'était ma punition jeu
finissait par croire que je ne mérite
plus que ça que c'était mon univers ça
je crois que c'est le danger maintenant
j'ai pu beaucoup d'alcooliques j'ai vu
beaucoup d'autres mâles
je sais que rester trop longtemps à
l'hôpital si le refuge est finalement
j'avais c'est là où je sentais que
personnellement je devenais un peu folle
c'est que je finissais par trouver cet
univers normal
et c'est c'est dingue c'est en mai chez
les dingues mais c'est dingue comme
univers c'est quoi c'est pas du tout
mais on s'habitue à tout
les groupements d'anciens buveurs il
pèse sur eux comme un volant de buveurs
d'eau et de dame patronnesse mais leur
action est essentiel car seul un
alcoolique peut comprendre un alcoolique
il a lutté pour lui même il luttera
désormais pour les autres et seul
soutien
qu'ils soient d'obédience religieuse
philosophique ou simplement
professionnels les groupements de
rejette personne ils prennent le relais
du médecin dans le rôle primordial au
départ perd un peu de son importance ce
sont aussi sur tous les autres qui
aiment jouer tous le secret de
polichinelle c'est à dire que tout le
monde autour de vous c'est que vous avez
des problèmes avec la boîte ou votre
entourage vos amis savent très bien qui
a contre blaine entre jouer l'alcool je
le vends de voir un diabolo menthe ou
impérieuse hydros
en transit pour icare quoi
il y avait payé le premier en effet la
deuxième du monde et ancien marin bombe
à leur miss a été pris et puis ça fait
que ça a duré quatre jours depuis ça a
duré quatre jours et je me prenais
important je pense que vous l'avez noté
c'est capital il a ri j'ai long de
commander un seul à bavay puis la vie
que c'est un bistrot plus ou moins mal
famé à l'horizon
et alors vous avez expérimenté ce que
les amis trois heures on dit tout à
l'heure est ce que d'autres ont vécu
c'est à dire que ce premier there est
difficile à limiter sais pas pour les
autres mais moi cependant pêcheurs et à
la rigueur soit la bouteille que ça soit
lui provient de la boîte cars et bus
bois peluches et soir il fera certes
arrive qu'elles n'arrivent pas m'arrêter
majorer le commandant où le pape a rien
à faire
bien sûr je suis alcoolique oui parce
que je ne serai jamais guéri je suis
sobre encore une fois pour aujourd'hui
je ne peux pas être guéri parce que si
je retouche un seul verre maintenant
c'est l'histoire de la pompe de tout à
l'heure si je retouche inverse même
maintenant et surtout maintenant je
remets tout en route et je reçois encore
pire que ce que j'étais il ya cinq ans
[Musique]